resuelve para x y nos dicen que por un
lado 5 x 3 es menor que 12 y satisface
también que 4 x más 1 debe ser mayor que
25 entonces vamos a hacerlo como lo
hemos estado haciendo vamos a resolver
cada una por aparte y después nos
acordamos que debe cumplir ambas gracias
a esta conjunción y por por la palabra y
muy bien entonces vamos a empezar de
este lado tenemos 5 x menos 3 es menor
que 12 así que lo primero que se me
ocurre es para ir despejando la x es
sumar 3 de ambos lados sumamos 3 de
ambos lados y estos se cancelan y me
queda 5 x es menor que 12 3 que son 15
muy bien ahora para despejar la x
podemos dividir todo entre 5 y no
tenemos que como 5 es un número positivo
no le pasa nada a la desigualdad
simplemente se queda igual verdad así
que no tenemos ningún problema con ello
vamos a dividir entre 5 estos se
cancelan y me queda
que x es menor que 15 entre 5 que es 3
vamos a ver qué pasa del otro lado del
otro lado tenemos 4x más 1 debe ser
mayor que 25 entonces restamos uno de
ambos lados restamos uno de ambos lados
esto se cancelan y me queda 4x debe ser
más grande que 25 menos 1 que son 24
nuevamente 4 lo podemos dividir
dividimos todo entre 4 como es positivo
no altera el signo de la desigualdad
estos se cancelan y me queda que x es
más grande que 24 entre 4 que es 6 muy
bien entonces ahora nos acordamos que
tenemos aquí un y así que esto debe
cumplirse x es menor que 3 y x es mayor
que 6 y aquí en este momento yo estoy
casi seguro que tu cerebro ya debe estar
pensando que esto está muy raro porque x
tiene que ser menor que 3 y debe ser al
mismo tiempo mayor que 6 vamos a ver
cómo se grafica esto tenemos nosotros
recta real de la recta numérica digamos
que por aquí digamos anda el 3 ok y lo
que tenemos de esta de esta de aquí es
que x debe ser menor que 3 ok entonces
x no puede ser 3 y nos tomamos todos los
que están a la izquierda por otro lado
tenemos x mayor que 6 entonces ya que
andy el 6 tomamos el 6 no lo incluimos y
nos vamos todo hacia la derecha entonces
que x sea menor que 3 y x sea mayor que
6 implica que se deben debe haber algún
momento en el que se se encimen estas
dos estas dos regiones sin embargo no
tenemos esa situación y por lo tanto
podemos concluir que no hay una solución
solución solución